this video is made possible by Backblaze
get a free 15 day trial at bag blaze
dot-com /bi a graphics imagine for a
second that there exists a hero a man
who has served his country in its
darkest hour and has made great
scientific breakthroughs who may have
saved as many as 14 million lives
how would you reward this man would you
give him riches awards accolades or
would you hound him from your
institutions would you destroy his
relationships before finally driving him
to suicide in 1954 the British
government they made the latter choice
that heroes named Alan Turing his crime
refusing to live in the closet a
mathematical prodigy volunteering
escaped a troubled childhood to become
perhaps Britain's greatest mathematician
the father of modern computing he
pioneered concepts of artificial
intelligence in cryptography and saved
millions of lives as a code breaker in
World War two
he also dared to be openly gay at a time
when loving another man could see you
not just jailed but destroyed by the
establishment join us today as we
journey through the inspiring life and
the tragic death of the mathematician
who took on the Nazis and one it is said
the first person we fall in love with
influences us for the rest of our lives
perhaps that's never been more true than
in the case of Alan Turing when the
teenage cheering met Christopher Morcom
in 1928 it was the start of a
relationship that would drive Turing to
do his greatest work so it's really
remarkable how close this meeting never
came to happening there are near
infinite universes out there where the
father of computing never met the Muse
who would inspire him the first
branching of the multiverse came in 1912
when ethel stoning discovered she was
pregnant with julius Turing's second
child at the time julius cheering was a
functionary in the Indian Civil Service
and there was no reason to believe the
new baby would grab anywhere but amid
the heat and humidity of the Indian
Plains but this was 1912 serious unrest
was starting to break out against the
British Raj and Julius
that his child would be safer growing up
in Britain and so it was that on June
the 23rd 1912 Alan Matheson tiering was
born not in Andhra Pradesh but in London
still India would powerfully affect
young Alan's life although Julius wanted
his children raised in Britain his job
required him and Ethel to live in India
so in 1913 they went back leaving Alan
and his brother John in the charge of
Colonel wort to compare war to the drill
sergeants in full-metal-jacket it would
be a bit of an understatement
Ward was a true military man he liked
boys who stood to attention not sissies
like young Alan who preferred reading to
ragga as a result Alan's early years
were spent constantly being bellowed out
until Ethel finally returned to England
and decided Alan would fare better at
boarding school and it's at this point
that we get our second great branch in
the multiverse in 1925 at age 13
Alan arrived at the prestigious
Sherbourne boarding school in Dorset by
now the boy was a veritable maths
prodigy unfortunately Sherbourne was a
school that prided itself on Latin and
Bible studies stuff that Alan kind of
sucked at he sucked so bad in fact that
the school actually opted to expel him
it was only after some serious begging
from Ethel that Alan was allowed to stay
that decision would prove important when
in 1928 Alan finally met Christopher
Christopher Morcom wears an attractive
black with a cheeky grin in the year
above him at Sherbourne he was also a
serious maths enthusiast the moments
Alan first saw Christopher it was like
time had stopped he took to following
the older boy around always sitting next
to him in class at first his behavior it
seemed to have amused Christopher but as
the weeks passed he and Alan began
spending time together debating geometry
and conducting science experiments
before long they were inseparable
it wasn't exactly a romance Alan would
write in later letters that Christopher
was probably aware of his young friends
romantic feelings but he had no desire
to act on them yes it is sort of that
classic story of a young gay man falling
for his straight best friends but it
didn't matter
Alan never became bitter about this
unrequited love he was just happy being
in the same room as Christopher as 1928
became 1929 and then 1930 the bonds
between Alan and Christopher only
deepens ballons grades they even improve
the danger of expulsion it drifted away
and then came February the 7th 1930 and
this idyllic life
it was shattered into a million jagged
pieces that day the two oculus is that
had afflicted Christopher since
childhood it went into overdrive he
collapsed it said that the moments he
heard the news Allen had a premonition
of his love's death on February the 13th
1930 Christopher Morcom died not yet
even a teen in assembly the headmaster
gave a heartfelt speech to mark his
passing but for Allen white use were
mere words it lost the one person in the
world who mattered him the one beautiful
thing in his life from that day on Alan
Turing had simply never be the same
again as nineteen thirty first dawned on
the rolling hills of Dorset Alan Turing
had been an aimless student and a
committed Christian by the time that
fateful year retreated over the horizon
he was neither of those things
Christopher's death had hit Turing like
a haymaker to the stomach
he cut himself off from his religion
began trying to scientifically prove the
existence of ghosts anything to give him
hope that his one love hadn't been
erased from existence
I worshipped the ground he trod on
Turing wrote to Christopher's mother it
was no exaggeration for the rest of his
life cheering would always remember the
first body he fell for thus life it goes
on in 1931 tearing left Sherbourne and
enrolled at King's College Cambridge
where he studied maths and dabbled in
anti-war politics yet even here the
ghost of Christopher it was never far
away
in 1932 Turing wrote nature of the
spirit a hopeful essay that attempted to
use the brand's new field of quantum
mechanics to suggest that our spirits
might live on in eternity cheering was
still clearly in the denial stage of
tragedy but this flirtation with the
otherworldly it wouldn't go to waste the
papers tearing studied during this
period would directly influence his
later work the next few years they
passed in numbed her break a cambridge
during at his first sexual encounters
with other boys he also earned a first
degree in mathematics aged 22 in 1935 he
was even made a fellow finally that same
year the broken young man discovered a
reason to keep on living
19:35 cheering began working on a famous
maths problem using some of the ideas
that had cultivated while researching
nature of the Spirit one year later in
1936 he finished his masterpiece on
computable numbers with an application
to the Aisne shankin problem sorry about
my German there but don't let this name
put you off you're still living with the
insights of this paper to this very day
the actual point of Turing's paper is
really beyond the scope of the video
today but part of it revolved around a
thought experiment using something
called a Turing machine to create the
thought experiment
Turing proved out you could take the
then human process of computing numbers
and create a machine capable of doing
the same that's right as a byproduct of
solving a maths problem
cheering invented the basis for modern
digital computers this was a truly
dazzling step of mathematical logic a
real once-in-a-lifetime achievement it
was also thought to be hopelessly
hypothetical something that was
theoretically sounds but nothing that
any modern human could ever hope to
build nonetheless cheering moved from
Cambridge to Princeton New Jersey in
September of 1936 to keep working on his
concept while he was in the USA he
happened to catch an animated film at
the cinema friends later said the
mathematician was completely bowled over
by Disney's Snow White particularly the
scene where the Wicked Queen makes an
apple deadly by dipping it in a cauldron
while whispering dipped the Apple in the
brew let the sleeping death seep through
and that my friends that's what we call
foreshadowing in 1938 cheering finally
return to the UK where he picked up a
job with GCC s the pre-world War two
British signals interception and code
cracking branch he was originally only
gonna stay there for a year in fact in
summer of 1939 Turing was offered a
teaching job at a university but as
you'll already know summer of 1939 was
when the fate of Europe changed forever
it was at this point the Turing was
really only weeks away from the meeting
with destiny
all right so it's time for us to rewind
the clock back a little on our story all
the way back to 1918
so 1918 at this point young Alan Turing
is still dealing with parents who
vanished to India at the drop of a hat
and has never even heard of Sherbourne
or Christopher Morcom but it's not a
silent hearing with time travel it's
here to look at it's an anonymous
looking German man named Arthur Shirley
as' in February 1918 is the first world
war still raged hobbies' had quietly
filed a patent for a new cipher machine
looking like a typewriter the machine
randomly scrambled messages as you input
them producing gibberish that only
someone with their own copy of both the
Machine and the cipher key could
possibly decode shabbiest names the
machine the Enigma in two short decades
it was going to be infamous Shelby US
originally wanted the Enigma on the
commercial market but it wasn't long
before the military came calling no
surprises in 1926 while Turing was close
to getting his arse expelled from the
Sherbourne the German Verma army
purchased the Enigma plans and started
developing their own even harder to
crack the Russian this was worrying to
Germany's neighbors for obvious reasons
in 1930 the Year Christopher died Polish
intelligence began secretly trying to
collect information on the new cipher
machine in 1933 they got their break a
drunk playboy and the German cypher
office named Hans Delia Schmidt sold
information on the Enigma to the French
Secret Service they passed it on to the
poles and under the direction of
mathematician Marion Raevsky Polish
intelligence was able to construct their
own indignant device the bomba the bomba
wasn't perfect they could decipher a lot
of Enigma traffic but it relied on the
Germans not updating their methods when
1938 ended with Hitler annexing Austria
and the Czech Sudetenland the poles
began to worry that maybe they needed to
show some other nations their stolen
device in summer of 1939 polish
intelligence they finally passed on a
replica enigma to both France and
Britain this was a decision they made
just in time on September the 1st 1939
Panzer tanks rolled into Poland by the
time a month had passed the entire
Polish state had been conquered by
Germany and Russia and Britain and
France
clared war okay so back in our main
narrative Alan Turing responded to the
outbreak of war by reporting to
Bletchley Park the hub of all British
code breaking efforts they're already
waiting for the young maths whiz was the
polls last gift before they were
conquered that a replica enigma that
tearing would use to save millions of
lives now just before we get into the
rest of the story today do you want to
thank our sponsor Backblaze who make
these longer videos possible this also
rather appropriate for today's computer
themed video and really the best way to
backup all of your files on your
computer is with back place as you guys
know I like to try the sponsors that we
have on this show and indeed today's
sponsor I'm actually trying in fact I've
been using for several years now I'm
using it right now on my computer both
as I record this video and as you are
watching it later my files are currently
being synced with back blazars servers
securely of course as I record this
video my computer's just churning away
in the backgrounds are uploading all of
the new videos that I'm recording
there's also of course uploading all of
my other files so I never lose any YC I
never even think about backing stuff up
anymore I can just rest assured the back
place is taking care of it all still not
have to call on them yet because I've
not had a hard disk failure or anything
like that it's a remarkably long streak
of luck I'll touch some wood right now
but I do know that if I do ever have a
problem and lose some videos or any
other files that I can just get in touch
with Backblaze and they will either
allow me to download those files are
more likely because it is terabytes of
stuff order a hard disk from them
they'll put all the files on it encrypt
them send it across to me and I can just
put that straight in my computer
[Music]
any new files changes they're all
automatically backed up so it really is
a hands-off experience viewers of this
video right now you can get 15 days of
Backblaze for free to try it out it's
totally unlimited there are no
additional charges or fees it's just
complete peace of mind I backup tens of
terabytes of data with Backblaze so it
really is totally unlimited and you
could see if it's right for you with
that 15-day free trial just go to
Backblaze comm forward slash biographic
s-- also going through that link help
support this show which is great
and let's get back to our story and how
cheering cracked that code so this point
in the story you might be feeling a
little confused
if Bletchley Park already had a replica
Enigma machine well why did they need
tearing the problem was the Enigma
ciphers they were constantly changing
the polish machine could intercept its
traffic but without that day's cipher it
was semi useless what Bletchley Park
needed was a device that could crack the
Enigma code no matter the cipher and do
it quickly this is where Turing's
strange genius came in now you may have
seen the benedict cumberbatch film about
Turing's life called the imitation game
and have a vision of volunteering as a
borderline Asperger's loner obsessed
with maths at the expense of all else
but the real cheering it wasn't like
that well maybe a little I mean it's
certainly true that he used to chain as
mugged the radiator so no one else could
drink out of isn't it
where a gas mask in summer to keep his
hay fever at bay but he was also a fan
of socializing and he liked to go out
drinking and dancing with his colleagues
so while Turing certainly was a spooky
maths genius while at Bletchley Park
please don't picture him as a 1940's
version of Sheldon klieberts just not
like that now the only going work on
enigma was heavy although cheering
helped build a machine known as the bomb
with an e to help decipher intercepted
messages many of them only came through
as gibberish short turn out to be
nursery rhymes the Germans had sent as
tests as 1940 got underway Turing was
reassigned to Hut 8 where he led a team
tasked with decoding German naval
transmissions this was important for two
reasons the first was that as an island
Britain had to import its food to
survive
great when you've got a friendly
consonant on your doorstep less great
when German u-boats are sinking all of
the maritime traffic coming to the UK
the second important reason is that it
was in hut 8 that cheering first met
Joan Clarke if Christopher was the great
love of cheering's life Joan was the
great friendship a mathematical genius
Joan had volunteered her talents at
Bletchley Park only to be told that
women can't do maths and she would have
to take a job as a secretary within days
though it had become clear to even the
knuckle-dragging and Ethel's running the
place that Joan's brain was the sort of
brain they were desperately looking for
and she was promoted to Hut eight but as
this was still the 1940s Joan was still
paid a fraction of what her male
colleagues earns still she and Turing
they really hit it off they went to the
cinema together and they went out
dancing as bombs rained down on southern
England the two mathematicians
friendship it began to blossom until in
early 1941 cheering did something
unexpected he proposed to Joan now since
you've watched this far and heard all
about Christopher you're probably
wondering why a gay man like cheering
would propose to a straight woman like
Joan Joan kind of wondered it - she knew
Turing was gay but she still said yes
it took a disastrous romantic vacation
for them to face reality and call the
whole thing off still Joan and cheering
they remained firm friends better still
they remained excellent co-workers in
hot 8 and hot 8 in 1941 was the nerve
center for the British fight back
against Hitler that summer cheering and
his colleagues developed a technique
known as Banbury smus which broke the
naval enigma codes wide open
suddenly the British knew where the
u-boats were ships could be routed
supply lines could be kept open and
lives could be saved looking back it's
really quite difficult to picture just
how close Britain came to starvation in
1941 we see the course of World War two
today like a narrative that can't be
changed with plucky Britain standing
alone always destined to triumph but
just as there are other universes where
Turing never met Christopher there are
other universes where huh Tate never
managed to crack those naval codes and
Britain starved in a brutal siege that
fall in 1941 buoyed by their success the
team at Hut eight wrote to Winston
Churchill asking for more funds
they only asked for a little thinking
the great man could never possibly have
heard of their small team and what they
were up to
so imagine they're surprised when
Churchill wrote back on October the 21st
saying that Hut 8 would now have access
to any amount of resources they needed
with the utmost urgency even the prime
minister knew that tearing and his team
were going to be the ones that saved
Britain by early 1942 Bletchley Park
analysts were decoding on average one
German message every two minutes or
around eighty four thousand a month yes
even as they saved millions of lives and
helped to decisively turn the war the
team were forbidden from telling anyone
about their achievements as a result
many suspected the heart eight-team of
refusing to help the war effort
Turing's landlady actually accused him
of malingering and called his refusal to
enlist a disgrace among people in the
know though Turing's reputation it was
soaring in December of 1942 he was
cleared for travel to the USA and given
a top-secret security clearance to help
American code breakers but by March 1943
had been recalled to Bletchley Park as
he was just too invaluable to be away in
America as a 1943 became 1944 the tide
of war began to turn in the summer of
1944 d-day dislodged the Germans from
their once on a saleable position in
France what followed was a slow-motion
collapse of the Third Reich that killed
more people than perhaps any other war
in history with his work wrapping up
cheering began to make plans for his
post-war career he decided that he might
build a universal computer around this
time he also seems to have decided to
start living mostly out of the closet
Turing was now a hero a man whose work
had saved Britain from starvation I mean
who could possibly object to a war hero
who just happened to love other men
finally in August of 1945 nearly three
months after the collapse of Nazi
Germany Japan formally surrendered to
the Allies the second world war it was
over for tearing this meant an OBE one
of Britain's highest honors it also
meant being told to never ever reveal
what had done Bletchley Park not the
tearing cares he was a hot property now
a genius that everyone was clamoring for
in 1946 the National Laboratory
commissioned him to build the first
modern computer the AC II had it been
finished
would have been the most powerful early
computer by far sadly though the NPL
bogged at the cost and decided to build
a smaller version known as the pilot AC
while the pilots AC was a milestone in
computing it was overshadowed by the
Royal Society computing machine
laboratory and Manchester's own effort
the first working electronic store
digital computer in 1948 keyring quit
the NPL and moved to Manchester to join
them it was around this time that Julia
steering finally died
sharings father had quit the Indian
Civil Service many years before but it
mostly lived abroad for tax reasons when
he dies it was discovered that had
rewritten his wills and even far more
money tutoring than to his brother John
like the gentleman he was cheering
disregarded his father's wishes and the
two brothers shared their inheritance
equally the 1950s dorms on a flurry of
activity volunteering in 1948 the
mathematician nearly competed at the
London Olympics making the shortlist for
the marathon events in 1950 he created
the famous Turing test for determining
if a machine has human level
intelligence finally in 1951 he began
working on the creation of artificial
life one of the very first people to do
so all in all things were going pretty
well for Turing now he was respected in
his profession mildly famous as a
mathematician and living as close to
openly gay as possible
in the 1950s now they'll no doubt recall
that we started this video by describing
cheering's life as tragic buckle up
because it's time for this innocent man
to be brutally destroyed
in the weeks before Christmas 1951 Alan
Turing was out shopping in Manchester
when he happened to lock eyes with
Arnold Murray a young man of around 19
Murray was a good-looking working-class
lat
that same day cheering took him out to
lunch and charmed him a week later Barry
stayed the night at Turing's house soon
the pair were seeing each other
regularly it was during one of these
romantic weekends that Murray started
complaining that he was always short of
cash
cheering off the boys some money but
Murray refused the next morning cheering
discovered money missing from his wallet
although he confronted Murray the boy
claimed he was innocent in the to
reconcile and that was the passion for
the next few weeks
Darren's money disappearing and Murray
refusing to admit his guilt it's likely
the well-paid Turing could have lived
with this odd arrangements whereas not
for what happens next
On January the 23rd 1952 keyring
returned home to find his house had been
burgled deciding Murray had gone too far
this time he called the police a week or
so later on February the 2nd in 1952
Murray
unexpectedly turns up on cheering's
doorstep screaming that he was innocent
he claimed a friend of his named Harry
had been the burglar and that it
targeted tearing after
Murray admitted that the pair were in a
gay relationship perhaps wanting to
believe his lover tiering reported this
new information to the police
not long after cops arrived at Turing's
house Turing was asked if this was about
Harry and it was but not in the way that
he thought unknown tutoring the police
had already arrested Harry when Harry
told them Turing was in a sexual
relationship with Murray the police
decided Harry wasn't the real criminal
here the real criminal was Alan Turing
that same day Turing was arrested on a
charge of gross indecency of having sex
with another man Murray was arrested
alongside him in late February 1952 the
pair attended a preliminary hearing
together Turing was bailed Mary went to
jail as a war hero used to moving in
academic circles it's likely tiering
never realized anyone would care that he
was gay but the lauren said otherwise in
the 1950s it was routine for police to
spy and entrap gay men you could have
saved Britain from starvation in World
War two you could have helped defeat the
Nazis but if he weren't a hundred
percent straight then you were worse
than a common burglar in March 1952
Turing pled guilty to one count of gross
indecency the court originally planned
to jail him but his lawyers convincingly
argued that Turing's work was
of national importance in the ends
curing was offered a choice one year in
prison or chemical castration
he chose chemical castration a course of
female hormones were released into his
body of iron implants in the thigh
chemical castration it was designed to
destroy libido and give you impotence it
also had horrific side effects an
increased risk of cancer was one and
extreme depression was another when the
news broke of Turing's conviction yet a
security clearance revoked his clearance
for travelling abroad as it likewise
went in the trash the years of turing
the genius were over in the eyes of the
british establishment he was now nothing
but a monster it was a cold wet Monday
morning when Alan Turing's housekeeper
let herself into his home on June the
8th 1954 it was now over two years since
the mathematicians trial and conviction
for homosexuality and Turing's life it
was in tatters gerron's public outing
had caused a rift with his family curing
thought his brother John was trying to
hide the fact that he had a homosexual
sibling and his mother's reaction to
tearing sexuality had been cold and
dismissive at the same time the course
of hormone treatment had wreaked havoc
on his brain and his body while under
treatment hearing had a small number of
sex dreams that convinced him that he
was turning straight he wrote to her
friends I've had a dream indicating
rather clearly that I am on the way to
being hetero though I don't accept it
with much enthusiasm still by 1954 the
worst was generally thought to be behind
him in April 1953 the implants had been
removed from Turing's thigh ending his
hormone course a month later had picked
up a new job at the cutting edge of
computing there had even been a sort of
reconciliation with his mother while
their relationship never fully recovered
his to come back from the lows of the
trial as the housekeeper crept through
the house that rainy morning in 1954 she
had no reason to suspect that anything
would be unusual the only sign machine
might have noticed was the faint whiff
of bitter almonds on the air upstairs
the dort Turing slap was open it had it
installed some years before and spent
his spare time experimenting with
different chemicals but the housekeeper
hardly noticed she was too busy staring
a lot lay on the bed his eyes closed
Alan tearing they dead on the bed
it's halfeatenapple beside him the
coroner's reports would later claim that
he had laced the Apple with cyanide and
bitten into it committing suicide in a
ghoulish shamash to Snow White
today it's generally thought to be an
unresolved question whether tiering
killed himself or accidentally poisoned
the Apple with cyanide gas while working
in his lab however a recent exhibition
at London's prestigious Science Museum
published the original coroner's report
for the first time in full it's noted
that there was so much cyanide and
cheering stomach that accidental
ingestion was effectively impossible the
Apple the coroner reasoned was a last
meal a final treat to take away the
bitter almond taste of cyanide on June
the 12th 1954 Alan Turing was cremated
at Woking Cemetery
despite his heroic wartime record
despite his pioneering scientific work
the press barely marked his passing he
was just another dead pervert what did
anyone care 13 years after Alan Turing
died in 1967 the British government
finally decriminalized homosexuality in
England Wales 42 years later in 2009
Prime Minister Gordon Brown issued a
formal apology to him finally on
Christmas Eve 2013 the Queen
posthumously pardoned Alan Turing this
led to the creation of Turing's law
which came into effect on January the
31st 2017 and posthumously pardons
thousands of gay and bisexual men who
were convicted for their sexual
orientation in Britain it was a hard
fight a Quadra of Conservative MPs tried
to filibuster the bill falsely claiming
that it would pardon convicted
paedophiles even in the 21st century the
prejudice which destroyed an interim it
still hasn't completely faded today it's
estimated that keyrings work on enigma
may have shortened the war by two years
saving millions of lives in the process
his work on computing artificial
intelligence artificial life and many
other fields is considered to have been
pioneering without this one remarkable
man who met such a tragic end you and I
would be living in a very different
world so I really hope you enjoyed that
video if you did please do give us a
thumbs up why not share this video with
a friend as sharing options below if you
think someone would enjoy this story
just have a go that why not also
subscribe brand new videos just like
this several times
week and please do check out Backblaze
our great sponsor they're linked to
below and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]